ce débat sur le niqab et surtout le
resserrement des règles sur
l'immigration
doit-il se retourner contre les
conservateurs depuis des années ils ont
beaucoup courtiser le vote des
communautés culturelles et des nouveaux
arrivants mais même dans certains comtés
qui leur était acquis en alberta on sent
une certaine hésitation c'est faux si
sylvain mascarons s'est rendu dans des
circonscriptions albertaine où l'on
retrouve une forte proportion
d'immigrants sic jour de recueillement
dans ce temple sikh du quartier muse
badminton ici comme ailleurs les
électeurs veulent du travail et une
économie qui va bien mais stephen harper
insiste pour parler des accommodements
des minorités religieuses promis par les
autres partis les politiciens croit-il
ferez mieux de bâtir des ponts entre les
communautés plutôt que les détruire ici
les fidèles sont sic pas musulman pas de
niqab donc mais la communauté ressent
une vague de méfiance envers les
minorités religieuses
une vague encouragés par les politiciens
pour séduire les québécois selon call me
tsonga il ne comprend pas ce qui se
passe chez les québécois qui considérait
pourtant ouvert et puis il y a les
enjeux de citoyenneté et d'immigration
les gens ici s'inquiètent des mesures
prises par le gouvernement conservateur
par exemple la citoyenneté d'un
immigrant condamnés pour terrorisme peut
être révoqué
les familles ont aussi plus de
difficultés à faire venir leurs parents
et doivent s'en porter garant plus
longtemps c'est comme si les immigrants
était un poids pour la société ajoute
que 800 gars il songe à voter libéral
stephen harper a mis beaucoup d'efforts
ces dernières années pour attirer le
vote des communautés immigrantes et en
alberta il avait réussi mais il semble
que les conservateurs perdent maintenant
des appuis auprès de ces communautés
les circonscriptions anciennement gagné
d'avancé sont maintenant le théâtre de
luttes plus serré ici sylvain bhaskar en
radio canada à edmonton